today we welcome to the program
democratic congresswoman Barbara Lee
representing California's 12th
congressional district also a candidate
for the senate seat currently held by
Senator Dianne Feinstein congresswoman
really a pleasure having you on I
appreciate your time nice being with you
Dave so I mean just to start with some
of the things that are that are going on
right now yet again we find ourselves in
this position of talking about the debt
ceiling and are we going to default and
who's posturing politically and for what
different reasons just as someone who's
been through a number of cycles of this
is this even remotely interesting at
this point or is it just a feeling of
exhaustion that this has to happen time
and time again
no it's not a feeling of exhaustion and
I feel like uh that the Republicans
especially the American Republicans have
politicized this to the point where it's
it's confusing oftentimes to to the
public when you uh incurred deaths and
remember a large portion of these debts
were incurred under Donald Trump uh with
his tax giveaways to corporations in the
mega Rich when you incur your debt uh
you're obligated to pay it and uh when
you buy a car you uh pay your car note
if you default on your car note they
repossessed the car and then if you go
to get another car the interest rates
will go up if in fact you can purchase
another car and and so why they're uh
politicizing this uh is primarily to
speak to their base and to the bank of
Republicans who want to basically uh
take away uh and cut Social Security cut
veterans Health cut uh Medicare and all
of the cuts that they want to take place
around using people's lives really as
host It Forward the debt ceiling and
that's unacceptable we must pay our
bills then we talk about how we
negotiate around the budget I'm a member
of the budget committee and the
Appropriations Committee and that's the
process that should be used at this
point do you operate in congress with
the belief that something like the debt
ceiling debate which feels so distant to
the lives of so many Americans who just
they go to work they might bring kids to
school they're living their lives do you
operate with the belief or assumption
that something like the debt ceiling
debate can be used both positively and
negatively electorally or that it's the
type of thing that just turns people off
well I think people need to uh
understand the Dynamics when you talk
about debt ceiling uh we have to break
it down and I looked at uh Kevin
McCarthy the speaker the speaker's
District I mean thousands of people will
lose jobs thousands of people in his
district will lose their veterans
benefit thousands of people their
retirement savings will be uh cut by at
least uh twenty thousand dollars so
thousands of people in his district
alone are going to be impacted uh when
you look at child care when you look at
uh early childhood education when you
look at uh college education young
people need to have college that's debt
free it's going to cost a heck of a lot
more for young people to go to college
if we defaulted on the debt so this has
real impact on people's lives and that's
why we're fighting so hard as Democrats
to get these Republicans to understand
we must pay our debts we didn't have
this issue under Donald Trump I mean I
think we raised the debt ceiling what
three times uh and that you know know
the Republicans were fighting and so
this is a political issue they're trying
to cater to the base to Marjorie Taylor
green and they really don't care about
whose lives that they're hurting but
believe you me Republican lives in
Republican districts and red States and
blue States people are going to be hurt
in a big way if in fact we don't do this
congresswoman with the benefit of
hindsight we're now able to have quite
quite a precise conversation about
something like Afghanistan if we go back
to the moment decades ago when you were
the only member of Congress to vote
against the authorization of military
force in Afghanistan after 9 11 and we
now go to Joe Biden carrying out some
version of the plan Donald Trump wanted
to carry out to get us out of
Afghanistan which while not perfect I
believe was absolutely the right
decision what can we now say in some
total about that now that we have this
these two decades AIDS going back to
your vote against that authorization all
the way through to the exit although
some contractors remain what what's the
what's the retrospective on Afghanistan
well first of all yes I voted against
the authorization because it came three
days after the horrific attack on our
country first of all thousands of people
were died still thousands of people uh
are are dealing with the health impacts
of what took place uh and it was a 60
word authorization three days after this
horrific attack that authorized not only
President Bush but any subsequent
president to go to war without coming
back to Congress that's unconstitutional
I mean we debate and authorize or not
the use of force for specific actions
not giving the executive branch
congresses which is the people's voice
authority and there's no way I could
vote for that that was overly Broad and
it was it set the stage for Perpetual
Awards fast forward to today we uh have
used this the administration all
Administration since the Bush
Administration has used this in I think
19 or 20 countries non-related to 9 11
41 times even uh and the Congressional
research study provided a Declassified
report it's been used for domestic
surveillance in our own country and so
this is was overly broad as I said it
was uh we needed to debate and come up
with an appropriate response I'm not
looking at the world through
rose-colored glasses I mean I know we
have to have some form of a response but
you have to have a rational response
that's appropriate not three days after
while people are mourning grieving and
look and angry and so now I'm trying to
repeal this authorization and I've got
bipartisan support to do that but the
problem and the sticking point is
there's some who want to repeal and
replace well what do you replace it with
the president has to come to Congress to
have an authorization to replace
whatever he needs the authorization to
use for as far so mine repeal
authorization stays in place for eight
months if president determines he or she
needs an authorization to go to war come
back to Congress we'll debate it and
provide it or not what's your view on
the withdrawal from Afghanistan which
you know it it wasn't perfect but I
believe it was the right decision uh
there was there were a number of
criticisms made of Joe Biden's
withdrawal but when the former president
Donald Trump was initially asked what he
would have done differently he wasn't
really able to articulate anything that
he would have done differently so it
seems that maybe there would have been
some chaos no matter when it happened
what's your sense of it
well my sense of it is that it had to be
done and yes it was chaotic it wasn't
planned but remember this was set up by
Donald Trump yes and he made and so uh
President Biden did the right thing it
could have been done uh in a more
organized fashion where uh we could have
uh I think uh done the it could have
really provided a better safe passage
for those especially who protected U.S
troops and who supported the U.S in uh
in Afghanistan uh the population but he
had to do this because in most military
officials will tell you uh we'd be there
20 more years and then 20 more years
there was no military solution in
Afghanistan and so why would we stay
there another 20 years our young men and
women serve bravely we lost a lot of
troops a lot of our young men and women
have health impacts that will be with
them for the rest of their lives types
we have to make sure that they have the
type of Medical Care the employment and
uh support that they need which of
course the Republicans are reticent to
give and and to support so yes President
Biden did the right thing no it was done
uh well no it was not done in an orderly
way but the historical context has to be
looked at in what Donald Trump promised
and how President Biden had to execute
right away and that was what took place
congresswoman I want to talk a little
bit about the senate race that you're
involved in right now this is a very
interesting race we we've interviewed
Adam Schiff your colleague and opponent
in that race we hope to speak to Katie
Porter also your colleague and opponent
in that race you know I get so many
emails about that race and one of the
big concerns that people have is that
there are three congressional seats here
that are going to be vacated which
hopefully would be filled by democrats
all for one senate seat which also if
Dianne Feinstein were to resign at least
in the short term Gavin Newsom would get
to appoint someone Gavin Newsom has said
if he had that opportunity he would
appoint a black woman Adam Schiff very
nice guy not a black woman Katie Porter
same thing so talk to me about the
Dynamics of this race are there
discussions within the halls of Congress
about the fact that these three
California House Seats will be up for
grab talk us through it a little bit
well I'm very focused on my uh race
first of all I have a very strong
Democratic District so I'm confident
that we will elect a Democrat uh in the
12th congressional district and yes I'm
running I uh was one of those that the
governor had considered once once uh
vice president Kamala Harris resigned
and of course uh the governor uh
appointed who was a good friend and
doing a great job Senator Alex Padilla
but the governor did say if he had an
appointing authority that he would
appoint an African-American woman but
let me tell you I am running and going
back to when he said that there were two
African-American women at the top of his
list one was uh at least we heard that
was mayor Karen bass and myself but I
decided uh when I after I talked to
Senator Feinstein in December uh that
that she was going to make her
announcement very soon whether she was
going to run or not run and I waited
until she made her announcement that she
was not going to run that was in
February of course my opponents were
running already yes but I waited I filed
the next day after she announced she was
not running and I'm running and I think
that my experience my background my
lived experiences as well as my
experiences as a negotiator and as a
progressive black woman and as someone
who fights not only for marginalized
communities but for everyone for the
middle class for Working Families for
people to have uh the quality of life
that they deserve an economy that works
for all people who have are not been
seen you know here in California we have
20 20 of our populations one paycheck
away from poverty no one in the Senate
is fighting for the poor and low-income
people and Working Families you don't
hear that debate you don't hear the
debate around climate change that uh and
and addressing climate the climate
crisis with uh environmental justice as
part of that in terms of what we do to
mitigate the harm of low-income
communities I I am running in this race
on a platform to talk about inequality
and housing and and my shared
experiences I had an abortion when I was
15 and a half years old I co-chair the
pro-choice caucus I fought to end the
Hyatt Amendment uh I had I talked about
what happened during my abortion not
only uh did I do that well I did that
because finally with the Texas decision
I felt like the public should know that
they're members of Congress who have
these shared experiences and I'm
inviting them to make sure that we
codify uh abortion care into our law and
so I have many many experiences as a
small business owner former small
business owner as a person who started
Community Mental Health Center my
background is mental health I'm and my
MSW psychiatric social worker mental
health is a big issue here in California
and throughout the country and so I
think my experiences my ability to
negotiate my standing strong sometimes
having to take on my party when I think
they're wrong and and I have courage
enough to do that because this is who I
am and of course there are gaps in the
Senate there are no black women in the
Senate of that perspective The
Experience uh representation matters
David representation matters it seems
there are basically three story lines
that are playing the largest role in
what are still the relatively early days
of this campaign one storyline is
identity as you talk about a third story
line is who is the true or most
Progressive and the third story line is
experience versus age and sort of like
what the voters are are looking for it
seems as though this could get a little
bit awkward in the sense that I know you
get along well with your colleagues from
from California it do you have some
conversation where everybody says hey
let's keep this clean or or it strikes
me as the type of thing that could
become awkward well I don't think it's
going to be okay I mean it's a campaign
right
but uh believe you me I know for a fact
myself people don't like uh campaigns
where uh you're hidden below the belt
and I was always like and I was mentored
by congresswoman uh rondelbs uh I worked
for Ron for 11 years he was first black
chair of the armed services committee
and Ron always told me and and everyone
on his staff you debate the policy you
they made experiences you debate what
your your historical context and how
you're going to use that for the future
to make lives better you don't hit below
the belt you don't go personal you don't
so uh no I I don't do that I mean I'm
going to defend myself yes if their lies
told about me I mean come on but uh I
don't think it's an awkward campaign
it's a this is a democracy people put
out their record who they are what they
stand for what they've done and what
they're going to do in the future and
then people vote based on who they think
will best represent them well I'll tell
you a campaign based on policy sounds so
refreshing given the context in which
the Republican party has abandoned even
pretending to talk about policy so that
I think would be welcomed by by many
many voters uh we wish you the best in
the campaign we've been speaking with
congresswoman Barbara Lee representing
California's 12th congressional district
I really appreciate your time and
insights today thank you David nice
being with you